attorney michael avenatti says new video
allegedly showing our Kelly sexually
abusing a minor is now in the hands of
prosecutors Kelly was released from a
Chicago jail on bail yesterday the R&B
singer pleaded not guilty to sexual
abuse charges
Jericka Duncan is outside Cook County
Courthouse shreeka good morning good
morning according to jail records a
woman describing herself as a friend
from the Chicago area paid the $100,000
needed for are Kelly's release take a
look at this video of him walking out of
the Cook County Jail yesterday afternoon
around 5:30 after spending three nights
behind bars the 52 year old Grammy
award-winning singer was accompanied by
his attorney neither spoke to reporters
Kelly then got into a black van and was
later spotted at a flagship McDonald's
and then a cigar lounge hours earlier
Kelly appeared in court before a judge
where his attorney pleaded not guilty on
his behalf
to all 10 counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse of four women three of whom
were under the age of 17 at the time in
the allegations dating back to 1998 now
meanwhile attorney Michael avenatti who
said he represents two of Kelly's
accusers says his legal team gave
prosecutors a second video that shows
Kelly having sex with a girl believed to
be 14 now Steve Greenberg Kelly's
attorney says he has not seen any of
this video evidence and maintains that
his client did nothing wrong our Kelly
is due back here in court in March
tarika thank you to be continued for
sure